[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for another teaser Ariana
we're getting so many of them we're so
excited for ariana grande to drop her
new music video thank you next which
comes out tomorrow it's so crazy to me
that we live in an age now where we got
teasers for music vests yes well I mean
I enjoyed the Caesar because we got to
see really you know what we're gonna get
we knew that she was gonna touch on
Legally Blonde and also bring it on 13
going on 30 and also Mean Girls Mean
Girls big one Jonathan Bennett is in the
video as well as Jennifer Coolidge I
love Jennifer Coolidge she is so funny
so so funny
and also her co-star Matt Bennett from
Victorious is in the foot is in the
video so I'm ready
look come on Ariana just give it to us
now please look I love a good throwback
I love nothing more than a good
throwback I love seeing people like
reprise their roles obviously we can
expect that from Matt Jonathan and
Jennifer right and so I I don't know I
think I think it's gonna be great I want
to see how far they go into these movies
yeah are they recreating specific scenes
well that's what it seems like but look
I will say this Ariana
you've built a huge hype I just believe
live up to it and I'm pretty sure she
will I'm the director talk about the
director a little bit oh yeah actors a
woman named Hannah lux
she's directed like six ariana grande
music video she's directed videos for
Demi Lovato and dj khaled and listen
when you do music videos on this scale
it's not too long right dump two movies
and television right so I mean the
director herself has a great track
record so this video I'm hoping is hot
I'm pretty sure it will be I mean it
looks like it will be